what you're about to watch is a protein
experience I'm gonna take you all the
way from the amino acids of a protein
into the tertiary structure in an
interactive exploration this video is in
two dimensions but I made a 3d version
of this video that is pretty awesome
you need a VR headset or at the very
least $15 Google cardboard to view this
so if you can get your hands on one of
those I highly recommend checking this
out in 3d there's a link to the 3d video
in the description if you're ready let's
begin our journey what you're looking at
right now is a protein turning slowly in
three-dimensional space this rotation is
artificial I'm doing this so that you
can see the whole protein but this is an
actual 3d structure of a real protein
scientists can crystallize proteins and
then shoot the crystal with x-rays the
direction that the X rays bounce off is
used to determine the actual 3d
structure so although individual
proteins are too small to be seen we can
use the x-ray crystallography data to
view them scientists can view the same
protein in different ways and we use
computer programs to make models or
renderings depending on the important
information we want to convey about the
structure in this video I want to
introduce you to the basics of molecular
visualization so that you can begin to
understand what you're even looking at
when you see a picture of a protein in a
textbook or if your instructor wants you
to look at a protein using one of these
modeling programs we need to start with
something small so we're going to look
at the amino acid alanine first notice
the color coding this is called CPK
coloring and it tells us which atoms
were looking at nitrogen is always blue
and oxygen is red take a good look at
the red atoms the program that I'm using
shows a double line to show the double
bond to the carbonyl of the amino acid
carboxyl group this structure is not
shown at biological pH notice there is a
white colored hydrogen atom on the other
oxygen amino acids ionize inform
zwitterions in the body so that hydrogen
atom would be on the amine group at
biological pH but typically we show the
proteins without any of the H atoms
anyway because they clutter up the image
too much so you need to remember your
rules for valence and ionization when
viewing this stick rendering of the
protein structure since you won't see
any of the hydrogen atoms here I've
arbitrarily colored carbon green but we
can choose any color for carbon however
it is unwise to color the carbon atoms
dark blue or red since you'll lose
structural information sulfur is another
element found in amino acids like
methionine here and it's CPK color is
yellow so you probably want to avoid
that color for backbone carbon atoms as
well before we move on let's look at
alanine once more see how when nitrogen
is on the Left the sidechain Group
points backward and when the carboxylate
is on the Left it points forward this is
because of the stereochemistry of that
carbon atom most amino acids are chiral
compounds and only one of the
enantiomers is found in human proteins
this plays a big role in the 3d
structure of the protein and determines
which molecules the protein will
interact with remember individual amino
acids link up in long chains to create
the secondary structure of a protein
here we're looking at a tripeptide
made up of cysteine valine and lysine
notice the nitrogen is next to a
carbonyl now we get an amide or peptide
bond when the amino acids link up this
isn't too bad to look at but things get
a little crazy once we start viewing
this 10 amino acid deca peptide
and it's even worse when we look at an
entire protein rendered as sticks we can
sort of start to see the overall shape
but the image is really cluttered and
confusing we can simplify this a lot
with a rendering called the alpha trace
this makes a line to the peptide bonds
of the protein ignoring side chains the
way that many proteins are rendered for
textbooks and journal articles is the
ribbon diagram though we're losing the
detail of the side chain atoms we're
seeing the overall structure of the
protein very easily along with the alpha
helixes and beta sheets that make up the
secondary structure let's look at this
beta sheet in a little more detail
suppose we want to prove to ourselves
there are strategically located hydrogen
bonds that stabilize this beta sheet and
hold the structure together it's
advantageous to zoom in and show the
stick rendering overlaid on the ribbon
diagram now we can add in the hydrogen
bonds I've colored these dashed lines
yellow notice how they connect blue
nitrogen atoms to red oxygen atoms this
is because the hydrogen atom is not
shown for clarity to understand this
rendering we have to know that the
nitrogen is actually an NH group and
that there's a hydrogen atom making the
H bond to the carbonyl oxygen now let's
take a look at the Alpha helix these
twisting amino acid clusters are also
stabilized by backbone hydrogen bonds
when we show the stick rendering and add
in the yellow hydrogen bonds will notice
they line up differently each carbonyl
group is bonded to an NH of another
backbone atom three to four amino acids
away another very common way to render a
protein is by showing the surface this
trace is the outside edge of the protein
notice in some spots on this protein
there are little holes where there are
no amino acid residues and this makes a
gap let's look at an enzyme in the
surface view
here we're looking at hexokinase the
first enzyme involved in the process of
breaking down sugar in your body because
this is an enzyme it catalyzes a
chemical reaction in a region of the
protein called the active site and this
one does so in a deep cleft on the
enzyme can you spot the active site this
crystal structure actually has a
molecule of glucose bound in the active
site let's show that as magenta sticks
and zoom in pretty neat glucose is
sitting there right inside that cleft
it's a little hard to see so let's
change our view of the protein to a
ribbon diagram another way to represent
the glucose molecule is using a sphere
representation kind of like the surface
rendering of the protein this shows the
space that the molecule is taking up
within the enzyme maybe we want to keep
in mind where the surface of the protein
is so let's overlay a see-through mesh
onto the ribbon diagram now we have a
sense of the surface of the enzyme the
secondary structure and we can see the
space that the glucose molecule occupies
awesome I hope you thought this was
super cool and are inspired to look at
some proteins on your own if you are I
put some links in the video description
for you to download the viewing software
I use and then you can peruse more than
a hundred and twenty thousand structures
of proteins and other macromolecules
available in the protein data bank